字幕: Emi Atarashi
校正: Yoshiaki Yamagami
夢のようなパワー
圧倒的な美貌を得て 活躍する
そんな魔法のような世界に
憧れたことは ありませんか？
メタバースという言葉は 知っていますか？
このメタバースこそが 今 お話ししたような
夢をかなえてくれる空間です
次世代のインターネット
とも呼ばれています
メタバースの概念は 複数ありますが
主には 現実とデジタルの世界をつなぐ
仮想空間のことだと 言われています
さらに その空間に
複数の人々が 同時にログインし
会話や触れ合いをしながら
あらゆる社会活動が行われる
そのような状態 そのものを
メタバースと呼びます
こんなことを言うと
SF映画のような 未来的なライフスタイルを
想像されるかと思いますが
そうではありません
メタバースは すでに存在しています
実際にその仮想空間では
多くの人間ドラマが 生まれています
一大事業とも呼べるような
プロジェクトも 立ち上がっています
今日 お伝えしたいのは
メタバースによって
難しいとされる
社会の課題解決すらも 可能にして
大きなメリットを得られた という
実例を挙げたいと思います
バーチャルマーケットという
デジタル空間上のイベントがあります
このイベントには 世界中から
100万人以上の人たちが
開催の度に 訪れています
これは 単なる動画の
視聴数などでは ありません
来場者は その空間に
平均３時間も 滞在しています
また 個人商店から ナショナルクライアント
レベルの 大企業のものまで
1000件以上のショップが
軒を連ねています
また 誰もが知る 有名ゲームやアニメ
映画のキャラクターが あなたを待っています
来場者は このイベントに
友達と一緒に 遊びに行くことができます
ショッピングモールのような場所や
アトラクションを楽しむこともできます
平面のECサイトに
誰かと一緒に出かけることは できませんよね
バーチャル空間でなら 可能になってます
ヘッドセットを被り 没入感に浸り
まるで デジタル空間に
自分がいるようなリアリティで
テーマパークで遊んだ思い出に匹敵するような
そんな体験を 得られるのです
これ 実は もう３年以上前から
展開されています
メタバースの一大事業であり
文化なんです
デジタルで作品が作れる
店を持って売買する
自動車の試乗体験なんかも あります
アパレルの接客も
ジェットコースターのような
アトラクションまで
さまざまなサービスが 提供されています
このように デジタル空間上で
同時に 多数の人が 遊んだり 働いたりする
そこに 経済圏があり
メタバースと呼ばれる世界が 実在しています
お伝えしたように
参加している人々も 大変多いです
そして 増え続けています
まるでこれから作られるような世界として
語られるメタバースという言葉は
古くは 小説『スノウ・クラッシュ』内での
ネーミングでした
ただ 著名人が
リスペクトから例えたであろう一言によって
一気に 公用語のように 広がりました
ここで 何度も言いますが
メタバースは 既にある世界なのです
バーチャル空間上では
日々さまざまなことが 起こっています
100万人規模でのサービスだけではなく
数え切れないほどのアイデアが
仮想空間に 構築されていってます
発明とも言えるものが
毎日 生まれているんです
ほとんどの人は「メタバース」や「VR」
「AR」という言葉を 知っていても
この空間内で起こっていることの
ほとんどを 知ることはありません
私たちが 普段 利用しているメディアなどが
VR空間上に
まだ 存在していないからでしょうか
便利な検索サービスすら まだありません
バーチャルから リアルへの情報だけが
まだ かなり分断されている状態と言えば
正しいかもしれません
そんなメタバース空間での
特別な事例を 紹介します
遊びやビジネスだけではなく
持続可能な社会につながるような
具体的な事例としての紹介です
東京の渋谷が 数年前に
バーチャル化されました
その中のファッションビルで
ハンディキャップを負った人が 店員となって
現実世界の人を 接客しました
彼女は足が悪く 現実世界では
ベッドから 起き上がることすら できません
昔から ファッションブランドで
働くことを 夢見ていましたが
現実には かないそうにない
そう言って 諦めていました
でも それがバーチャル空間であれば
かなうんです
「アバター」という
仮想空間を動き回るための体を使えば
自分の理想の姿で 走り回ることができます
このVRの力を使って
彼女は 夢だった
ファッションブランド店員として
働くことを 実現しました
現実の世界の渋谷にいる人々を接客して
もちろん しっかりとしたお給料を
得ることができました
夢が かなったのです
もうひとつの事例として
バーチャルマーケットの主催者でもある
フィオという人物は
もともと 社会人として 活動していました
ある日 重度のうつ病を患ってしまい
人と会うことすら
全く できなくなってしまいました
妻子がありながら 数年間も
働けない状態で 大変 悩んでいました
そんな中 VRに出会い
デジタル空間上での
コミュニケーションであれば
問題なく 活動することができる
そこに 希望を見い出したのです
仮想空間の中であれば 生きていける
でも 当時そこには
経済圏など なかったんです
生きるには それを作るしかないと考え
生まれたのが バーチャルマーケットです
驚きの集客力を持ち
個人から 国際的な企業も
こぞって参加するような
一大事業を生み出しました
現実には 誰にも会わずに
仮想空間上でのコミュニケーションを頼りに
親友とも呼べる仲間に出会い
今では 多くの人に求められる事業を超えた
マーケットを作り上げたのです
これは 多くの人々にとって
メリットになるような
メタバースで どういう可能性を
秘められているかが分かる
事例になるんではないでしょうか
ビジネスでいうならば まさに
ブルーオーシャン 夢のある世界です
そういった市場かもしれません
今 ご紹介した事例のように
メタバースは
さまざまなメリットを もたらしてくれます
社会的な課題を解決することすらもできると
私は 信じています
これからメタバースは
一般的なものに なるでしょう
ただし それは
世界の常識というのからは
ちょっと かけ離れているかもしれません
お伝えしてきたように
チャンスが もし
そこにあると感じられるならば
いち早く今の常識を
自ら 変えていく必要があります
人類はこれまで 何度も常識を更新して
進化してきたと思います
それを 少し 早めるだけなので
それほど大変なことでは ないと思います
今日 この話を通して
伝えたかったことがあります
常識とは 過去に誰かが作ったものだ
ということ
ふと こう疑問に感じることがあったとしても
なんとなく 常識だからといって
考えることをやめたこと ありません？
僕はあります
それを そのままにせずに
行為に出して 届けてみましょう
それを続けてみましょう
常識というものは 声を上げた人を中心に
周りの力が加わって 再定義されて
最適化されていくはずです
そうして 新常識を持って触れる世界からは
これまで 思いもよらなかった存在
メタバースでの
一大事業を制御させる人が現れて
出会えるかもしれません
自分がそうなるかもしれません
メタバースの中で
凡人が天才に 昇華するかもしれません
ただ 僕自身は 特別な才能はなくて
一般の人間です
でも たくさんの才能たちに
出会えてきました
その結果 バーチャルマーケットの
運営する会社の代表を やらせてもらってます
そうした機会に恵まれたであろう唯一の行動は
先ほど申し上げた 常識を捨て去ることを
日常的に やってきたからです
僕のような凡人でもできるんですから
難しくないと思います
気持ちの問題だと思いますね
それをやることによって たくさんの人に
たくさんのメリットに出会えるのであれば
むしろ どんどんやるべきだと思うんです
そして このメタバースに可能性を感じる人が
少しでも このトークでいたならば
ぜひ 一緒に
その世界を広げていけるようになれば
うれしく思います